in whitehall the prime minister chaired
a meeting of the emergency committee
cobra as the taliban take huge swathes
of afghanistan a crisis worsening by the
hour i must say that i don't believe it
was
in vain because i do think when you look
back at what has happened over the last
uh 20 years there was a massive effort
to deal with a a particular problem that
everybody will remember after 9 11 and
that was successful it was right it was
it was worth it and what we must do now
is not
turn our backs
on afghanistan
in the southern province of helmand for
so long the base for uk troops the white
flag of the taliban was raised outside
the governor's residence as if the last
20 years had never happened
corporal mark wright died in helmand a
land mine exploded as he tried to rescue
a fellow soldier
for his ultimate sacrifice he was
awarded the george cross for bravery
now his father feels his son's death was
in vain
they thought they were out there doing a
job
uh trying to help the people there
and to be taken out when the jobs were
done it's usual with them and all these
people that lost their lives were all
severely injured families
and turmoil
[Music]
members of the afghan community here in
glasgow are mourning
massoud najib's cousin and his son died
in a shooting earlier this week in kabul
showing us pictures of the car riddled
with bullet holes his relatives inside
the growing crisis for afghans summed up
in one horrific image
people were happy and they were saying
okay it's safe and everything but these
days
the situation is very bad and people has
nowhere nowhere to stay
their own places are not safe and even
when they're coming to kabul
and they don't have houses and they're
sleeping in the streets and the parks
and they have no food or nothing
britain has spent years trying to find a
way out of afghanistan but events are
drawing britain back into the fierce
fray
nick martin sky news